in this video I get really in depth on
the actual scaling of a sales team
process the training process the
onboarding process the management
process Etc so that you can scale sales
within your organizations the interview
process what we're testing for is the
speed of response you can test work
ethic by how quickly they get back to
you because you are a lead to them
number two somebody who's intelligent so
if somebody sounds like an idiot then
it's the impression that they're going
to be giving of your brand the next one
is you want somebody who can listen so
someone's dominating the conversation
they're talking they're you know motor
mouthing it's not a good idea you want
somebody who's kind of an ambivert
somebody you can listen and can talk
when it's time and socially aware you
want someone who's coachable and so you
can measure coachability by saying Hey I
want you to role play with me in this
situation and you just give them a
little bit of context I don't care about
how well you sell me I just want to hear
you talk through things and then what
you'll do is you'll give them feedback
and then ask them to try again now if
someone can take the feedback without an
ego then you have somebody who's
coachable and if they make Improvement
on the second try then you know that
they can improve if someone is not
coachable and they do not take feedback
well you can already know way ahead of
time that they're going to be terrible
fit for the team now at this point they
have to transition their general
knowledge of sales to your specific
product or service now I think one of
the things that's overemphasized is
proud technology which underemphasized
is Prospect knowledge what we should be
focusing on is who are we selling to
more than what are we selling because
who matters more in the sale the person
the product the person right so we want
to understand their problems so in depth
because if you can explain to somebody
exactly the problem that they're going
through they will buy whatever you have
because they will believe that you so
intrinsically understand what they're
going through once we've decided to hire
this person I like to have a 14 day
onboarding period what is covered in the
onboarding period is that we want them
to listen to sales calls that are good
now if you don't have any sales calls
that are good like I would recommend you
go and sell and do it well and then
record those calls and have them listen
to it you want them to be bathing in
good sales all they're doing all day
long is listening to sales calls
listening to sales calls listening sales
calls and you can see if they watched it
based on most software once they've
watched let's say about 40 different
sales calls they're gonna have a pretty
good idea now in between those watchings
you want them to work on the script the
script should be in my opinion a
question based framework it's a
framework of questions that lead someone
naturally to the conclusion when I
review the salesforcement portfolio
companies when they're trying to improve
there wasn't a core decision that was
articulated the sales people in general
would multiple times throughout the
sales say do you have any questions for
me do you have any questions for me and
that's an indication that the
salesperson doesn't know how to close
clearly not following the script because
you're not asking the prospect to come
with more reasons to not buy right
you're asking them to make a decision
it's going to be very clear at the
beginning of the call which is
clarifying why we're here and then
labeling them with the problem so that's
the closer primary clarify why they're
there label them with a problem overview
their past experiences and pains once
you have that you've gathered enough
info you say cool I think you'd be a
good fit can I tell you about it you get
invited to sell which is the S and then
you explain in very short analogies why
you think you're going to be able to
solve two to three of the problems that
they explained and then you ask for the
sale and then enr are explaining what
their concerns and then reinforce the
decisions and so once we have a script
do you want to boil down the decision to
the most basic unit possible and the
reason you have to do that thinking is
because you don't want them to try and
think about what the decision is you
want to give them the decision that they
have to make by the end of the call and
so if you're selling a B2B service it
would be like the decision we have to
make is whether you're going to make
more money on your own than you will
with us in excess of our thing what most
people do is they just talk for 30
minutes and then they just present the
price and they just don't have any
structure of the conversation and they
don't actually do any fact finding they
go on off all of these all these changes
why are you here what is your problem
what have you tried to solve here's how
I think we can help you given what you
just said to make this one decision
which is can we help you more than you
could on your own yes or no fantastic
close that's it once we've clarified
what that scripting needs to look like
and that's big picture there's obviously
wording but for the sake of this video I
want to talk bigger picture so once you
have that and this person is watched
themselves in sales they're studying the
script what you want to do is you want
to role play with them you want to role
play with them every morning during that
process so they get better at it once
they pass the role play test right and
if you're like whoa that sounds like a
lot of work well it is a lot of work to
build a great sales team once they sell
you on them being able to have this
sales conversation then you put them on
the floor on a half schedule you're not
going to give them a full schedule
because you want them to blow through a
ton of leads you give them a half
schedule the second half their day
they're still reviewing the calls they
had and then you're still meeting with
them twice a day beginning of the day
and a day the second week of this
training when you're reviewing the sales
costs with them they now have fresh ones
that they went through that you're going
to give them feedback on here's how you
have these meetings when you do sales
manager meetings you're communicating
the goals which in sales is usually
pretty sure straightforward you're
making sure they're motivated and you're
training them that is the point of the
job you motivate and you train as long
as they're clear on what their kpis are
30 minutes before the call that you have
with the new trainee you listen to one
or two of their sales calls at 2x you
know speed take written notes of all the
things that you would want to improve
when you get on the call with them which
should happen immediately afterwards
because it's going to be fresh in your
mind you then look at your notes and
then you want to bold or prioritize one
to two highest impact things that they
can do now there's probably a hundred
things they're doing wrong but you just
want to start with the highest impact
things and then you give them those
things and it takes about five minutes
to communicate that 30 minutes to review
and write the notes five minutes to
communicate the thing that the one to
two highest leverage things that they
can do to improve and then 25 minutes
where you role play again with them with
the new changes and then they go back
the next day they do more calls you
listen to see if they did the thing they
didn't do the thing roll play again the
next day you listen to recordings now
maybe they got it right you say hey keep
doing that you're getting better now
let's also do this thing when someone
says I got to think about it when
someone says I have to talk to my spouse
or when someone says that's a lot of
money let's drill this overcome this is
what I need you to say you have to Flex
that muscle as many times you can get
those reps in within that 25 minute
period And so as you're scaling a sales
team you need to do that with all of the
Reps that is what Sales Management is
it's not just like sitting there having
one weekly meeting and checking in on
people and asking them what their
pipelines at you need to be reviewing
sales calls with written notes
prioritizing where they can improve the
most and then communicating and drilling
them on those things maintaining the
culture of the team through three things
one is having a leaderboard that is
Visual and up to date at all times sales
people are competitive you want to
Foster that competition number two is
that you want to have clear kpis and
some sort of bonus and we like every 30
days to 42 days every four to six weeks
having some sort of big little thing
that they can brag about winning some
sort of sales competition of the
different objectives that we have
optimized for the one that has worked
best for all of our portfolio companies
is optimizing for cash up front there's
three things one is the leaderboard two
is the kpi in competition and the three
is that you have to cut the bottom 10 on
a quarterly basis if you're not cutting
you're communicating with the team
that's okay to suck and it will drag
down the culture of the team and so the
job of the manager besides training is
motivation motivation comes from culture
and the standards that we set for
ourselves and what you agree to tolerate
and so fundamentally Sales Management is
a skill of Tolerance is the person who
tolerates the most is the one who has
the weakest team you can tell the
difference between the winning teams and
losing teams usually by the coach how
can you have one coach go from a losing
team in the NFL to almost undefeated
team in one year because of the
leadership because of the culture
because of the Mojo because we say we no
longer tolerate these things like if you
want to be here this is a world-class
sales organization and if you are on
this team it means that you're agreeing
to them there was a time a few years
back where our sales team got a little
bit bloated got a little bit fat and so
I ended up cutting more than half the
team and then I had a meeting with
everybody afterwards and I wanted to
reset the tone and I was like guys if
you're here it's because a we value and
we think that you're solid but B is
because we think that you're going to
buy into the vision of what we will have
for the future which is we want to build
a world-class sales organization and if
you want to stay on this team then it
means that you're agreeing to that and I
don't want to say that you're inherently
agreeing to that I want to let you guys
sleep on it because tomorrow if you want
to quit that's fine you just let me know
in the morning no harm to foul I'd
rather you just tell me because what
we're going going to go through is going
to be a significant change and so if
you're a sales manager coming into an
organization you say these are the new
standards of what we will do I expect
you to all attend our 5 a.m training for
an hour where we drill together I expect
you to show up on time to every single
call I expect you to clean your
pipelines every single day and that you
put the call notes in the CRM as
required if you do not do those things
even if you're the best closer on the
team I will fire you are we clear and
the reason I do that is because I want
the culture of this team to be one of
excellence in everything we do because
if it's worth doing it's worth doing
well and so you have to set that tone on
the team to get them to want to raise up
and that's where the leadership of sales
manager is so important as a side note I
have rarely found that the best
salesperson is the best sales manager
sales managers tend to be more giving in
general and more stable as people
there's less emotional highs and lows
they are more even they need to be the
rock of the team that people look up to
no one respects a sales manager who says
do all these things and doesn't do it
themselves and so they have to emulate
or exemplify what work ethic looks like
what following through looks like which
finishing your checklist every day looks
like being first to show up for the
meeting in the morning before everyone
else does like you have to lead by
example the last piece I want to hit on
here is the Cadence which is what
frequency are we talking to our sales
people the first 14 days you're going to
be talking to that person once or twice
a day when they're getting onboarded
once they get out of that training
wheels period which is the half week if
they meet the quota which is the minimum
allowable close rate or whatever metric
you want to use then they can get a full
schedule once on the full schedule
they're still kept on that and everyone
understands that if you drop below kpi
for two weeks you go on a pip which is a
performance Improvement plan which means
you go basically regress back to being a
trainee which means I now have to train
you the way we were and I'm going to
take even more attention to fixing your
calls and getting you back on track if
after the next two weeks you still
haven't improved you're all that's the
name now when you hire people you also
set that expectation this is how this
works this is a dangerous place to work
we do that because we expect Excellence
you want them to be fired up they'll be
like let's [ __ ] go the Cadence after
you've graduated someone from trainee to
full time is you would meet with them on
a weekly basis and then maybe after a
year every other week if they're just
killing it but most times most sales
people meet on every basis just to clean
the engine check in on things give them
a couple of tidbits hear them out Etc
the structure of those calls already
outlined in terms of how you give
feedback that same feedback structure
applies to all of the existing guys too
which is an hour per guy per week is for
the sales management and so you take 60
to here maybe two calls because you can
listen to it on faster rate and then you
can have your written feedback and after
you have the call with them you want to
message them or email them the Salient
blocks and if you're an organized person
which I recommend you be if you're a
manager I like having a tab of all my
sales guys and having the things that I
want them to work on each week so that I
can just date it and say like last
Monday I said these two things come back
this Monday and so when I'm reviewing it
the next week I'm saying this is the two
things I tell them to work on did they
improve it yes no cool when I come back
to that call I'm like hey we said these
two things did you do it did it results
in you making more deals awesome cool
big meeting Cadence you've got your
weeklies you've got your monthlies
you've got your one-on-ones that happen
on a weekly basis or more frequently if
they're on a performance plan or a
trainee and then you have as a team
daily huddle end of day huddle the end
of day is a short just like hey how's
everyone doing checking in cool awesome
make sure you clean your pipelines Etc
the early morning one is a training if
you want you can make it optional and if
you're on a performance plan or you're a
trainee it's mandatory with the right
culture teams most guys always attend
that's the overarching structure for
scaling a sales team in an organization
the only other thing that can happen is
that they will lose conviction that's
when sales can get cold the things that
keep people motivated are the
competitions because that keeps things
fresh because it's a very repetitive job
but also reading testimonials of clients
they recently sold and the results that
they're experiencing and you do that so
that they feel like they're good guys
because a lot of times sales can feel
very hunt and kill but you want to sell
from a place of empathy genuine empathy
not nice guy but like I really want to
help you which means you need to make a
decision and that's what like I'm not
going to let you hide in your excuses
again because I really am trying to help
you not say I am because I've seen guys
just like you change their lives by
doing this and I know you're just
putting [ __ ] up and you're afraid
and that's okay because we're going to
help you you have to have somebody who
who's willing to push through the know
because they believe in the product and
the transformation the other person is
going to experience not because they
have their ego tied into it and they
want to close the sale to be number one
you get there backwards and you do that
by having people who were clients hop on
a sales call and talk about their
experience the second best thing is to
watch videos of testimonials with the
team before you start the day in the
early morning huddle and then the third
is just just read them out loud yourself
and ideally what you want is if you're
going to read them out loud have the guy
who sold the person read the testimonial
because then it'll double down on their
conviction